et qui dit on va rappeler que les
experts en informatique qu'est ce que tu
vas nous montrer aujourd'hui il rit je
veux montrer tout ce que je faisais
l'expliqué déjà la dernière fois à
savoir qu'un portable est très intrusif
et qu'on peut rentrer dedans et faire ce
qu'on veut absolument à partir maman à
une certaine compétence
il faut rappeler quand même la loi c'est
quand on espionne quelqu'un sans son
autorisation
on laisse quand même un an de prison et
45000 euros d'amendé
donc on a le droit dans le cadre de la
loi d'espionner ses enfants sous
responsabilité légale
la cedh employés si vous leur fournissez
un portable professionnel ou bien
quelqu'un qui est sous tutelle droit on
a brodé avec important que tu donnes un
portable à un mec il va dire qu'il faut
l'exclure des dalles
mais samantha moi qui dois rester dans
le cadre professionnel je pense que je
vous offrez un portable
alors après le cadeau alors et donc
ouais leur nez ça pourtant ce que tu dis
là c'est déjà intéressant ce troisième
cas c'est quoi le troisième cas c'est à
dire que ben alors là en fait on va
faire un test informatique ouais surtout
ce qui reste de la vie privée de nos
jours on a utilisé un portable privé
donc ça va c'est légal mais c'est pas à
reproduire à reproduire chez soi bien
entendu alors et tu va nous donner aussi
des conseils pour être très prudent mais
bien de ne pas se faire espionner voilà
je vous dis alors c'est très simple tu
nous as on après un t1 téléphone bref
c'est ça et tu va infiltrer ce téléphone
tu va nous dire comment tu fais
jean-michel je crois que vous avez un
téléphone
voilà c'est un smartphone oui voilà
exactement donc vous avez des photos de
dents vous avez des vidéos vidéos allumé
ou éteint il est il a allumé où il est
enfin il est allumé lanta maroc mais on
est alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
comment vous allez faire
alors ce qu'on peut faire c'est qu'on
peut avoir accès aux appels vous allez
faire pour alors là déjà vous avez
envoyé un truc là amel et déjà est
envoyé en fait quand il ya quelqu'un qui
a cliqué alors je sais pas si c'est vous
si c'est vous mais j'ai envoyé un simple
lien directement et il ya une
application qui s'est installée dans le
téléphone directement dans les fichiers
système du téléphone vous avez envoyé et
même un mms genre voilà installer cette
application est là il a juste cliquer
dessus et installer et l'application
s'insérer dans les fichiers système est
totalement invisible sur le sur le
téléphone
voilà ça il croit que ça ajoute on a
envie d'expliquer dessus sur 80 ans vous
aviez gagné
juste un numéro de téléphone et il ya un
lien s'est même pas quoi paf
merci alors on a un expert informatique
sur rfm jeu bien que vous connaissiez
des frites mais on a quand même un
expert informatique là c'est quand même
ces déchets tels fichiers t chez le
fromager de boucher qu'il a donné des
conseils merci alors donc nous aimerions
que renvoyer un lien à jean michel maire
ainsi ça et donc vous allez voir comment
il va espionner qu'est-ce qu'il faut y
voulait qu'ils restent là il peut sortir
directement même dans les coulisses et
on y voir ce qui se passe dans les
caméras que ce soit et extérieurement et
intérieurement à la caméra un coin mais
parce que vous avez pu voir même le film
et on va voir ce qu'il faut on va
pouvoir le film et voir ce qu'il fait
exactement quoi faire et à voir tout
dans l'écran derrière et c'est
incroyable c'est court tiens un truc
donc est ce qu'on peut avoir accès aux
photos par exemple de jean michel maire
on peut avoir accès aux photos
jean-michel mère belge a récupéré
quelques unes j'ai vu qu'il ya eu
quelques petites échange des dons des
photos qui ont été supprimées également
et a donc décollé de potosi prix women
des poubelles des produits ils arrivent
à les réduire et faire exactement donc
grâce à votre lien vous avez même les
photos supprimées au moulias membres ont
exactement
alors je vais pouvoir par exemple jean
michel y voilà donc la voilà par exemple
vous êtes vous êtes rentré dans son
hôtel alors là on a juste un petit bug
technique
voilà la classe et jean michel jarre
connaît exactement est ce que peut faire
un re démarrage du téléphone est ce
qu'on pouvait faire un redémarrage du
téléphone sert quoi il est à ira le
voilà il devint évident qu'elle a
olivier habite bien entendu qu'ils aient
eux ne s'est pas produit servir de son
producteur et blouson mais c'est d'assad
c'est même pas la peine
attendez n'ont même pas la peine tu vas
pas la peine c'est bon à trop tard ou
tard on va trop tard ben là je lai gelé
sur l'écran alors ça y est alors c'est
quoi un club démarre voir dans le bar
qu'aux filles vous voyez jean michel a
lancé ouais elle annoncé le redémarrage
oui donc vous pouvez vous attendre que
le téléphone du coup redémarre pour
pouvoir rediffuser la caméra que ce soir
ça veut dire que quelqu'un distance il
faut que gainey ça vous pouvez donc voir
ce qu'il en train de faire exactement
c'est incroyable ah oui il doit deux
lignes 1 2 3 4 ah oui code pin de 3,4 kg
top d'accord 1 2 3 4 le code puis
maintenant combien de temps vous pouvez
voir ça à la voix on a presque à
l'infini à la salle a fini sur un an sur
deux ans exactement ça ne savez ça
s'arrête pas il ne s'arrête pas donc
c'est une caméra espion corps qu'il a
sauté les
caméra espion exactement à une caméra
espion qui à l'heure mais même de voir
l'écran alors le sont pour l'instant
avoir l'image regardez l'image donc
voilà donc on va voir ce que vous pouvez
voir regarder tout ce que j'ai une
confirmation qu'ils soient redémarrer
voilà d'accord état du périphérique
j'aimerais que ça roule bien
voilà voilà on est plutôt vers un lit à
et c'est un certain c'est un truc de ouf
et une raclée portable un filtre est
c'est fini c'est morvan s'est félicité
denis totalement regardez moi on regarde
et regarde et on voit si on voit tout ce
que vous faites là c'est rien c'est
génial et donc on va voir si on va
pouvoir voir en vidéo jean michel qui
est dehors
regardez voilà peut-être se reconnaître
au wifi aussi parce que s'il n'est pas
connectée c'est sûr que d'être connecté
au wifi aussi voilà bien entendu ce
qu'ils voulaient tous connectés horrifié
merci on a deux abrutis de vente et donc
quand le portable est éteint vous pouvez
pas le faire et dès qu'il est rallumé ça
vous fait un petit nom les âges invita à
oued accord hélas les mêmes leçons
ouais parce qu'à distance à quelle
distance n importe quelle distance à
n'importe quelle distance il peut partir
à paris un à lorgner à lyon peu importe
il fait ponte et là ils passaient
fallujah là c'est l'intérieur de son
oreille c'est incroyable non moi lorsque
je peux aussi switcher c'est à dire que
je peux faire apparaître la caméra
externe vous avez la caméra que furent
avoué puis vous avez mérité donc on peut
switcher également la caméra en deux
côtés et lui navigue sur son téléphone
il s'en rend pas compte à dire qu'ils le
voient pas alors il a reçu un message là
on peut la voir oui c'est quoi comme
type de message whatsapp sinon et on a
bon peuvent avoir accès à ces photos là
les photos que j'ai vu c'est pas
possible autrement je suis sûr à côté
olalala sa navigation et lucie on peut
aujourd'hui regarder on a tous les crs a
toujours mis ouais c'est un peu coupé je
vais vous dire qu en remettre voilà on a
notamment quelques photos qui ont été
supprimés on peut avoir accès aux photos
ouais alors attendez un petit instant
mais ça veut dire que lorsqu'on supprime
et jean louis nauges pas rien a touché
le toit une photo elle n'est jamais elle
n'est jamais complètement supprimée en
fallait pas supprimer ce n'est pas une
exception supprimer tout couac sur tout
cas ce type de logiciel sur téléphone
dire qu'elle appartient moment où la
photo a été prise
été envoyées sur un serveur elle est
rediffusée justement sur cette
plateforme là et donc même si vous l'a
supprimée elle reste sur le serveur
c'est quelque chose de similaire à
icloud mais c'est pas un club ouais ça
ça à moi c'est pas tout à fait pareil
téléphone parce que là c'est pas du tout
c'est pas en plus c'est pas son iphone
dans l'occurrence j'ai quelques photos
dont une de vous alors je n'arrive pas
vraiment à rocourt en quoi les photos
c'est quoi les fautes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et le pire c'est qu'il est vraiment
rentrer donc il faut pouvoir découvrir
et sacd risbo le faire partout c'est à
dire vous envoyer un sms à quelqu'un il
ou s'est terminé alors est mort
exactement et moi j'entends très souvent
sur les réseaux sociaux les gens dire
oui moi j'ai un iphone c'est pas un
android est-ce que c'est sécurisé est ce
que c'est pas sécurisé alors il faut
savoir que très récemment il ya eu une
faille qui est qu apple vient de
découvrir qu'ils ont sorti une mise à
jour collectif à ce niveau là qui
permettait d'accéder au tram ou wifi
c'est à dire de récupérer toutes les
données qui transitent est entre
l'iphone et une box en question cette
faille a été corrigée par du coup le
nouvel ios qui est sorti
il faut aussi savoir que quand l'iphone
11 est sorti il ya google qui ont
détecté cinq failles dans google par
concurrence ou pas des équipes de
sécurité de google qui ont détecté cinq
fois entre l'ios dix élus es 12 qui
permettait justement de s'introduire
dans les iphone au même titre que j'ai
fait sur un téléphone android os faire
exploser comme ça tout le monde peut se
faire espionner quand je téléphone et à
tant que téléphone est éteint ccc on
peut rien faire quand le téléphone est
un c'est plus compliqué c'est sûr qu'on
peut rien faire après il ya certains
types de téléphone ça dépend du fayard
noir alors on va pas entre un état et
technique mais quand les téléphones
éteints il ya certains modèles comme
celui ci qu'on peut rallumer d'accord et
donc quand le téléphone est allumé donc
vous pouvez avoir accès c'est à dire
qu'à quelques années avec sa femme en
train de discuter vous avez le son et
l'image de votre ordinateur et vous dit
tout exactement incroyable et j'en
reviens aux gens qui disent oui mais
j'ai un iphone c'est sécurisé il faut
savoir encore aujourd'hui sur ay es13
on peut déjà ibérique et un iphone c'est
très facile alors pour être pour faire
très court
qu'est-ce que j'aille vrai qu'est-ce que
route ne jailbreak c'est pour les iphone
le roots et pour les téléphones android
d'accord pour les personnes lambda ça
sert à quoi route et de fabriquer un
téléphone ça permet d'avoir un accès
total aux systèmes d'exploitation celui
ci ce qui signifie que vous vous frottez
votre votre iphone vous aurez accès à
des applications vous n'aurez pas sur
l'appstore pour les personnes plus
expérimentées
ça permet de déjouer justement les
failles de sécurité que les mises à jour
d'apple et d'android fond sur la plate
forme à chaque fois d'accord alors quels
sont les trois conseils qu'on peut
donner aux téléspectateurs vous avez
donné dans un instant mais juste avant
est ce que tout le monde peut se faire
espionner son téléphone tout le monde
c'est à dire philippe tout le monde
n'importe qui c'est vraiment tout le
monde donc là je les fais dans ce cadre
là sur un téléphone android la prochaine
fois je peux vous faire sur un téléphone
iphone sans aucun problème quoi d'accord
week end combien de personnes comme vous
en france sont capables de faire ça ce
qui en a beaucoup
alors je dirais qu'il n'ya pas besoin
d'être aujourd'hui il ya des plateformes
sur terre qui permettent de le faire il
ya pas besoin d'être un grand expert il
faut quand même se connaître un minimum
à l'informatique pour pouvoir voit la
route et le téléphone masqué le routage
mettre l'application là masqués dans les
fichiers système non c'est quand même
tout un petit process mai
il ya des personnes qui seraient
capables de le faire compliqué alors
c'est pas si compliqué qu'on le pense
c'est compliqué mais c'est pas si
compliqué qu'on le pense c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez votre épouse il
en train de dormir lui installer un
logiciel de danse c'est faisable en
quelques et donc on peut la voir avec
avec jean michel maire après
éventuellement c'est incroyable justice
sur les sur les sms même quand ils sont
supprimés aussi on peut les avoir
derrière si on a réussi à voir les
photos on peut avoir les sms les appels
whatsapp ah mais c'est pareil c'est la
même soin de sa peau si vous avez tissé
exactement une chose hélas si vous
regardez mon logiciel jeu peut même voir
télégramme
les échanges qui sont pas cryptés sur
télé verwee ça veut dire vous avez tout
tout tout tout tout prix la totalité
donc dit qu'il a l'air très inquiet non
mais juste de vérifier se trouve sur
téléphone et a été infectée comment on
peut faire quand on veut faire vous
faites appel à des sociétés de sécurité
informatique mais même là ce sera
difficile pour eux détecter si elle bat
regardez moi d'ailleurs michel mr moi je
peux essayer de le trouver mais demande
à jean michel maire de ria les
téléphones de zapper dessus dedans il va
rien trouvé de suspect d'accord dont un
gardien du dogme n'est pas le voir comme
ça il faut vraiment rire annexe est
invisible
sinon c'est inutile ça ne s'est pas
lisible c'est invisible parce que si
c'était visible ça servira à rien si
votre épouse ou quelqu'un qu'on espionne
voix qui l'espionnaient ya pas
d'utiliser les sionistes qui va
supprimer l'application directement ou
changer de téléphone alors dans un
instant vous allez me donner trois
conseils pour éviter l'espionnage des
données aux téléspectateurs ça on attend
ça avec impatience que là on est tous en
train de filmer surtout isabelle parce
que oui il ya des fautes du cap nuls
dans sont l idri ch et expert en
informatique et depuis le début il vous
fait flipper il fait sa fille idriss
on a donné un téléphone à jean-michel ça
dépasse au téléphone mais c'est un
téléphone voilà que vous avez un fils t
exactement intégré exactement explorer
est exactement ça va un fou jean michel
a fait des vidéos il a reçu des sms vous
vous n'avez accès à tous voilà est-ce
que vous avez même accès aux derniers
numéros qu'ils ont appelée puisque il ya
numéro s'était affiché dont il ya plein
de gens qui sont en train de la plaque
voilà alors la paix passait pas le
numéro d'aujourd'hui c'est un numéro
comme ça c'est le numéro que j'ai mis
énormément dans la carte sim aussi
d'accord fusée
là pour moi je peux pas excéder une cité
bloqué parce que tellement de
d'internautes qui essayent de rentrer
dedans mais j'ai entendu un mot de passe
qui pourront rien faire
moi ce que les conseil que je pourrais
donner pour éviter justement tenter
d'éviter que ça se produise sur un
nouveau portable
quant au reste des conseils basiques
parce que ça pourra toujours se produire
on va pas se mentir
mais bon quand même les deux trois trucs
qu'il faut pas faire du tout vous voulez
zéro risque oui prenez un nokia 32 10
avec aussi pensez pas 32 deal est alain
1110 avec la petite antenne non vous
n'aurez pas de problème de piratage 5110
nerfs alem l'acheter c'est le genre de
nouvelles choses c'est vrai nom mais
c'est le genre de téléphones qui
utilisent les dealers tout simplement
pour pas être localisé précisément et
sont localisées avec des bornes
téléphoniques donc ya pas de
localisation que l'accord est même le 32
10 il est dangereux
oui est-ce qu'on peut infecter le
serpent mais c'est vrai mais revenons
mais réellement iliad il ya certains
anciens modèles de téléphones qui sont
un filtre à bhl et d'autres non d'accord
de 50 ans fils trappe c'est le dos qui à
quoi 50 51 10 et tous les vieux modèles
qu'on les petites antennes saeco
ericsson tout ça certains ericsson
samsung bale et sam sont via les
nouveaux samsung et les anciens donc ça
dépend vraiment notre rôle à la le
caillou capella comme ça ah bah ça aussi
c'est parfait c'est parti ça va mais
c'est le tour est celui-là le startup
j'adore et bah tiens je vais prendre à
cet article enfin si vous voulez rester
vraiment à la mode et avoir un téléphone
chaux-de-fonds ovine mois tout le monde
a envie d'avoir watsa par envie d'avoir
avec soi reste à la voie de la revois ce
book bas vous prenez vous êtes fous de
votre téléphone est faillible
si vous allez mode vos téléphones et
filles très clairement mais après donc à
les petits conseils comme jeudi pour que
j'avais déjà expliqué lors de la
dernière émission mais je vous en donner
d'autres par exemple mais son téléphone
à jour donc la version ios ou android ça
peut paraître un peu bizarre pour
certaines personnes c'est très facile il
suffit d'aller dans les réglages et de
faire une mise à jour du logiciel
ça permettra provisoirement de ne pas
être piratées jusqu'à ce que la nouvelle
faille sorte parce qu'il faut savoir que
le premier android et le premier iphone
ils sont sortis en 2007
on est aujourd'hui en 2020 ça fait 13
ans ils font des mises à jour ils ont
des dizaines de milliers d'experts en
sécurité informatique et ça jamais été
aussi faillible que ça l'est aujourd'hui
donc franchement il ya moi où je me dis
je vous donne des petites clés mais y'a
pas d'astuce magique ça n'existe pas il
ya quoi d'autre sinon quand vous
téléchargez une application par exemple
vous avez téléchargé chroniqueur candy
chronique à bientôt
j'ai fait constitue ces moments là c'est
ça vous des fois vous télécharger des
applications sur le sur le ps store
et puis on vous demande
cd de pouvoir autoriser accéder à vos
appels à vos sms votre localisation
alors que ce n'est pas forcément utile
lors des 3 allez vous faire ans l'ex bas
vous mettez refuser tout simplement les
gens mais tous autorisés parce qu'ils
disent sinon l'application ne va pas
s'installer
vous mettez refuse et refusera refusé
d'installer un logiciel type coyote ou
gps c'est normal qu'on vous demande
d'accès à votre localisation dans ce
qu'il faut l'accepter
n'allez surtout ne pas autoriser les
accès ou voilà à tout ce qui sur l'e
mail
est-ce qu'il faut ouvrir il faut pas
ouvrir les mêmes parce qu'il ya plein de
mails de voyance aussi court soit par
exemple syrie le mois je reçois souvent
cyril il faut que je te dise une
personne autour de toi et là ils mettent
trois petits points tu dois aller
cliquer sommet web apps enfin pour moi
ça me paraît logique de ne pas cliquer
alors pour un nécessaire dans lambda je
me doute que ça peut être compliqué et
audio si vous avez gagné une audi a8 1
me disais c'est vrai et vous dites-vous
n'est gagné au loto que vous allez
gagner un gp son héritage et gagner quoi
que ce soit que vous envoyez votre trip
pour pouvoir récupérer au fond ça ouais
toutes les âneries fin ça c'est des
techniques typiquement congolaise ou
sénégalaise apte à grandir et où il m'a
envoyé moi agrandir le pénis à web à toi
je sais que tu l'as fait alors
heureusement ça n'a pas marché c'est
pour ça qu'il est privé
elle abat des faux mails qui proviennent
de partout c'est à dire soit orange
m.sissoko rien nous et vous dites que
chez les mms moi je vais vous dire une
chose les multinationales et les grosses
boîtes comme la vôtre par exemple ou
comme n'importe quel autre
elles sont le plus plus faillible pas
par le biais des directeurs mais par le
biais des employés cirque c'est surtout
les employés qui font des erreurs et qui
campe sur des liens
en donnant des mots de passe qui donne
ensuite accès à d'autres systèmes etc
etc pour remonter et r1 piratage qui
sont ces gens donc à laver ça fait
flipper est ce que vous avez d'autres
questions et vous si vous avez des
questions sur twitter serait bien qu'on
fasse apparaître des questions s'il vous
plaît en régie de téléspectateurs parce
que là je sais que ça réagit beaucoup
beaucoup de gens sont très intéressés
par ce qui se dit donc s'il vous plaît
en régie manille oui j'ai failli me
faire avoir tout à l'heure par un mail
que j'ai reçu et aurait été le voir
c'est un mail tu disais kelly de hotmail
mon fournisseur qui faisait vous avez
été piraté il ya une tentative
d'intrusion bien sûr été signés j'ai eu
l'impression que sa faconde direction et
puis j'ai été le voir il m'a dit surtout
alain clique pas moi je sais que c'est
un fake et tout ça il y avait le nom
d'une personne donc ces redoutables a
bien sûr piégé tout cas il peut se faire
un fait cela en fait vous pouvez cliquer
sur le lien le tout c'est de ne pas
télécharger ce qu'on vous propose de
télécharger et c'est surtout de ne pas
rentrer d'identifiants sur ce site en
question sans avoir vérifié d'intégrer
du site comment on vérifie l'intégrité
du site tout simplement en regardant le
nom de domaine on regarde pas https ça
n'existe pas vous voulez c'est un par
exemple recevoir un mail de outlook qui
vous demandent par exemple de
réinitialiser votre mot de passe vous
cliquer dessus
voyez bien que dans le navigateur ses
marques et outlook points comme pas
outlook avec trois homes et outlook avec
2 au 20 cd des conseils simples quad et
si vous nous rejoignez sachez qu'on est
espionné que votre téléphone et votre
smartphone sont extrêmement dangereux on
l'a vu tout à l'heure ce garçon en vous
envoyant mms
vous cliquez dessus il peut même voir
voilà ce que vous faites avec la caméra
de votre téléphone vous entendre à
distance c'est incroyable alors il ya
d'autres questions si vous avez des
questions n'hésitez pas valérie benaïm
oui tout à l'heure vous avez dit que
vous pouviez récupérer même des choses
qui avait été supprimée comment est-ce
qu'on peut supprimer définitivement une
photo un une correspondance lundi
dernier le téléphone en deux alors c'est
vrai qu'il y avait un bon conseil qui a
été donné c'est à dire que effectivement
de remplir la mémoire du téléphone avec
de multiples vidéos de les re supprimé
de la re remplir de les re supprimé pour
vraiment c'est de vider le cache un
maximum mais ce sera toujours
éventuellement récupérables on peut
jamais vraiment savoir ce qu'on va
pouvoir récupérer ou pas dans ce
cadre-là par casser le téléphone en deux
on peut rien faire honnêtement c'est
surtout si vous êtes espionner en mer
mais d'éteindre tout va bien le rallumer
un jour si on l'éteint et coup aux
relations l'état la résomption l'étain
et qu'on le touche mais ça n'est pas le
modèle d'affairé modèle où là on peut le
rallumer par le biais d'un jour les
iphone par exemple sur les iphone non
pas encore mais les
façon très faible pour voir les sms les
appels et à beaucoup d'autres options
disponibles aux iphone on pourra faire
une autre démo d'accord on a une on à
une question d'un tweet hausse il ya
vraiment aucune application pour savoir
si notre téléphone est piraté alors vous
avez des applications comme bitdefender
des antivirus kaspersky caillavet avast
mais bon ça reste vraiment d'un point de
vue mobile c'est quelque chose qui est
pas compétent sur pcc des antivirus qui
fonctionnent assez bien parce qu'ils
analysent le comportement des pc sur
mobile c'est plus des choses commercial
qu'on vous propose et qui ne fonctionne
pas dans une application comme je vous
ai cités là sur le téléphone que j'ai
donné à jean michel maire elle ne
fonctionnera pas détecte rien car oui
question de castaldi informatique parce
qu'il ya une fonction effacé remettre
les réglages à 0 ça sert à rien car ça
sert à rien ça m'amène à la factory
recettes on pourra récupérer une partie
de données je peux pas vous garantir qu
est ce qu'on pourra récupérer accord non
mais une grande partie sera récupérée
mais ce qui est fou c'est par exemple
lorsqu'on vend un téléphone lorsqu'on a
fini son téléphone etc enfin qu'on veut
passer à un téléphone suivant on
voudrait on va vous les faces et on va
le rendre tout propre tout neuf et on va
le vendre à quelqu'un d'autre
donc c'est à dire que la nôtre l'autre
peut à nouveau à récupérer d'une manière
générale il ya très peu de personnes
qu'on les quelques uns qui ont les
compétences ou qu on vraiment envie de
récupérer ce qu'ils avaient sur le
téléphone la personne en formation à ce
qu'on l'enlève mais il ya quand même des
risques où il ya des risques réels il
allait pourvoir un pote m'a donné un
téléphone et pourra jamais trouver
l'application sur internet il fallait se
payer un abonnement ça payé mais assez
cher quand même 50 70 euros par mois ah
ok du coup j'avais cliquer et le j'avais
je vais retrouver toute cette photo de
son téléphone
je vais envoyer il habitait en flip
savate ou 70 euros c'est cheikh salman
ali mise car on voulait quelque chose de
plus rock et me demande bien qu'assez
téléphone donnez le moi puis je le
client de la surnommer c'est vrai alors
c'est vraiment vraiment le plier en deux
camps jeudi pliant 2 c'est un terme avec
un marteau casillas est l'invité de on
fera une prochaine démo c'est comment on
fera une prochaine démo vous prenez un
téléphone vous casser la vitre avec un
marteau je vous récupère les données dda
comme ça mais une fois qu'il est pliée
en deux que des composants à l'intérieur
sont cassés brian divan l'on pourra plus
rester de votre grille alors et vous
raconte tout support bleu clair avec les
be bop
alors tous super efficace que vous êtes
ce que vous êtes déjà fait avoir par
voir quelqu'un encore plus efficace que
vous parce que rien ne dit que vous même
vous êtes pas victime de ça
ce qui m'est arrivé
où j'en suis aujourd'hui si vous voulez
c'est que j'ai été victime de quelqu'un
quand j'étais mineure quand j'avais 12
ans je me suis fait pirater mon compte
facebook
et c'est à partir de là que je suis
informaticien je me suis dit mais merde
comment ça a pu se produire et j'ai été
depuis tant d'années là-dessus quoi
question d'y en question si on restaure
son téléphone est ce que l'on peut se
désinstalle inouïe alors ça dépend qu'à
l'appui espions et quels modèles de
téléphones faut savoir que chaque
téléphone à un logiciel spécifique que
vous les achetez au qatar en france en
espagne ça reste des versions ios des
versions android mais c'est un noyau
gens si je puis dire un noyau différent
pour chaque fire meurs donc j'ai envie
de dire oui et non oui
idriss ya plein de questions un jour par
exemple voilà qui arrive merci d'avoir
été là
[Applaudissements]